For centuries, these two islands
in the South Pacific
were home to Māori people.
They call it Aotearoa.
the indigenous Māori population
was rooted in a sacred relationship
with the land and surrounding waters.
They organized society and an
intricate system of tribes...
and subtribes.
They flourished.
But by the end of the 1800s
roughly 60% of them
were dead.
Due to new diseases,
displacement, and war
all caused by Western colonizers
who called the islands:
New Zealand.
Over the course of several decades
more than 90% of collectively
owned Māori land
had been taken by the British Crown.
They not only took the land,
but they took a river.
That river meant...
everything to us.
There were hundreds of my ancestors
that were taken.
We lost language.
We lost land.
We lost our way of life.
You kind of wonder at times...
Who am I?
What am I?
But today...
something groundbreaking is happening here.
A kind of reparations, or,
as they refer to them in Aotearoa:
settlements.
Land and cash settlements for Māori
accompanied by historic formal apologies
from the government.
"Another first: this law includes an apology."
Our iwi received $87 million
in cash from the crown.
17 land blocks are being returned
with deeds and titles.
$170 million...
peanuts.
It really is peanuts.
I'm here in Aotearoa
to take a closer look
at Māori people's
long fight for sovereignty over their lands.
And all the mixed emotions and
outcomes that come with it.
I'm also here to explore how
a similar movement for redress
could gain more steam in the United States
for Native Americans and
Black people descended
from those enslaved in America.
Māori people have gotten
the British crown
to recognize the harms of their pillaging...
apologize and pay.
What can we learn about reparations
from their story?
At the end of the 18th century
about 100,000 Māori lived Aotearoa...
and were part of various tribes
still known today
as iwi, and subtribes,
hapū.
Though they weren't functionally a nation
they controlled every corner of the islands.
But in the first half of the 19th century...
Europeans began to arrive
by thousands of ships
especially people from England.
Far beyond the small settlement
of British missionaries already living there.
Disputes start to occur between
the new arrivals and Maori
particularly around use of land.
The settlers saw the land as property...
something to be owned
which was in conflict with the Māori view.
And there were new outside threats too.
Māori learned that the French and
other Westerners wanted their lands.
So they began signing this
Declaration of Independence
in 1835.
Rangatira — or Māori chiefs
used the document to make a firm statement
to the rest of the world...
that authority with an Aotearoa
rested with them.
The document declared
"he whenua rangatira"
which translates to "an independent state".
With new nationhood, they petitioned
King William IV
for support and protection.
And a few years later, the British government
and Māori chiefs
saw the need for another formal document.
There were opportunities
to both engage further
with the British Crown
as treaty partners in having
a strategic, political
but also trading partner.
In 1840, more than 500 Māori chiefs
signed this document:
"Te Tiriti o Waitangi" with
the British Crown.
Te Tiriti is the foundational document
at the center of the story.
Its creation opened up the
gateway to the unlawful
British colonization of the islands.
It's been vigorously debated
because there are stark differences
between the Māori
and English texts of the treaty.
The Māori text says that the rangatira
have "tino rangatiratanga"
which translates to "absolute authority"
over their lands, resources, homes,
and "toanga" or "treasured posessions".
But the English texts states that the rangatira
"cede to Her Majesty the Queen of England..."
"all rights and power of sovereignty."
Those big differences:
One vision saying you see ceded sovereignty
the other one saying
actually, you get to govern yourselves
and look after yourselves.
You know, it's quite fundamental,
really, in terms of
how things rolled out across our history.
Within a Māori worldview,
within a Māori philosophy...
it's not actually possible to suddenly decide
to give up that sovereignty to someone else.
The British proceeded to assert control
over the islands after the treaty was signed...
claiming that under British law
they had the power to
set up a government.
They appointed a governer,
William Hobson
and formally established Aotearoa
as a colony by the end of 1840.
There were land sales or
purported land sales
where they engaged with
perhaps one of the hundred owners...
or, you know
100 people that had rights to a piece of land
but engaged with 1 person that
effectively would sell the entire block.
Where I'm from in Wairoa
was a really big significant
purchase of land
which was framed as a
sale and purchase.
But my ancestors, we're told by
the Crown Purchase agent
either you sell us this land
or we will confiscate it.
And so it those kinds of coercive practices
which also resulted in
significant land loss.
There was resistance of our people to that happening.
Conflict over land and resource
came to a head in 1860.
In the decades long
New Zealand wars
Māori people battled to protect their land.
But they were severely outnumbered
by British troops
who killed more than
2000 Māori.
Through the wars, the British confiscated
massive amounts of land.
Supported by a new law that said
the crown could seize the land of anyone
who had rebelled against the Queen.
Māori were allowed to defend
their claims to land in court...
but mounting a defense usually included
prohibitively expensive legal fees
and travel costs.
This land confiscation
triggered a breakdown of the
Māori economic base
and disrupted the communal culture
of Māori identity.
Plus, diseases that European colonizers
brought to Aotearoa
continued to kill Māori
in large numbers.
In 1840, shortly after Europeans
began arriving by the shipload
80,000 Māori lived on the islands.
By 1896, only 42,000 remained.
Meanwhile, the Pākehā population
those who were white or non-Māori
ballooned to 701,000 people.
An estimated 88% of
Māori lands were taken
It wasn't until decades later
that Māori activists would force
the British Crown
to reckon with this history.
Even as a child growing up...
in the first 15 years of our lives,
for me, was around
how to be a Pākehā.
It was about how to talk like them...
dress like them...
sing like them.
By the 1950s, New Zealand's government
had rewritten
the history of the Crown's colonization
into a rosy story.
One newspaper from the early 1900s
quoted a politician who said
"The Māoris had always been loyal
to the British Empire."
"New Zealand was a country that
had never been conquered....
or annexed."
"It was a mutual agreement."
There has been a real perpetuation
of the myth
that, you know, New Zealand
has great race relations.
And often the Treaty of Waitangi
is held up
as the example of that
is to say, look
we negotiated this sovereignty by consent.
But in practice the oppression
of the Māori
had continued for more than 100 years
after the Treaty of Waitangi had been signed.
"For the first time in history,
a reigning British monarch
visits her Māori subjects."
Māori military men who
fought for the crown
in both World Wars were not given
the same benefits
as Pākehā after their return.
Disparities became glaringly
apparent by the mid century.
Compared to Pākehā, Māori had
poor health outcomes
like double the child mortality rate.
They were over 5 times more likely
to be incarcerated
and both Māori men and women
had lower incomes than their
Pākehā counterparts.
And in 1953, the Crown introduced laws
that further for some Māori
to sell their land.
Those laws, along with World War II
helped incite a mass migration of Māori
from rural lands to cities.
Living in Christchurch was
a whole experience.
Living in a white town.
You kind of hold your breath and go
holy hell, I never experienced racism like that.
As a young boy, I wasn't too sure
what the hell was going on
but I knew there was something wrong.
I can't help but think about
the similarities here between
how Black Americans and Native Americans
were treated in the United States
around the same time.
Many Black Americans and
Native Americans
enlisted and fought in World War II...
but upon their return from the war
they were shut out of benefits
that were extended to white American.
Like home loans and educational funding
provided by the GI Bill.
Black Americans were segregated through redlining
and the benefit didn't extend
to Native Americans living on tribal lands.
Over time, the compounding impacts
of racial discrimination in the US
showed up the same ways they did
for Māori populations.
With a higher infant mortality rates...
Black incarceration rate that was
just over 5 times higher
and much lower networth.
But by the 1960s, with many Maori
now gathered in cities
they were better positioned
to challenge leadership.
"In America, black people are treated
very much as colonized people
because we're used, we're brutalized
the police in our community
occupy our area
our community, as a foreign group
occupies territory.
The advent of television
helped Māori tune into the
Black Power Movement
and the activism of Native Americans
in the United States.
But the people have to stand up and demand
and they have to understand
that they have a right.
In America you have quite a few
movers and shakers...
that make a difference, and that was
all through marching.
Members of the activist group
Ngā Tamatoa
channeled these lessons into their protests.
They were part of a movement to revitalize
the Māori language te reo Māori
which had been activelly surpressed
in schools for decades.
And later Ngā Tamatoa helped launch
one of the biggest protests Aotearoa history:
the Land March of 1975.
"It's been joined since early this morning
by young and old."
"And in spite of rain, which set in
late in the morning...
the marcheer's spirits are still high."
It's a huge project.
A lot of our people actually
didn't support us.
They think we're a little bit naive
or a little bit nutty.
The protest action needed someone
who could rally Māori together.
Her name was Whina Cooper.
Whina Cooper was a respected Māori elder
descended from the Te Rahrawa iwi
who dedicated her life to Māori land rights
and to the rights of Māori women.
She was nearly 80 years old
at the time of the march.
We need somebody like that
that can bridge through the heart and the minds.
So we got the face.
We need a slogan.
And so we came up with the slogan:
"Not one more acre of Māori land be sold."
Not one more acre.
After all these 135 years
we have only 2 million acres left.
The march took 29 days and
grew to include 5000 people.
They came from all over
the north and south islands.
And when they arrived at Parliament
marchers presented a petition
signed by 60,000 people
that laid out their goals.
They were here to establish new laws
from Māori land based on their
own cultural values:
communal ownership of land within the tribe.
Protest movements anywhere in the world
makes a difference.
If you don't protest,
nothing will happen.
And people will think
everything's all right.
It's not.
The Crown, long recluctant
to acknowledge the harms
of its colonization
was forced to respond.
They established the Treaty of Waitangi
Act of 1975
to investigate contemporary breaches
of the 1840 treaty.
But it wasn't until after another
decade of protests
that the Māori won the right to give
the investigating tribunal
retrospective powers...
the ability to investigate grievances
going all the way back to 1840.
While this tribunal could only offer
recommendations for government action
it opened the door for a kind of reparations.
The government decided
to create a pathway to dozens
of land and cash settlements
that are ongoing today.
I really excited about that
to be able to do some more
research for us there
to share our story.
For us to be able to have this type of conversation.
At last we can talk to each other about it.
At last we can have a voice we can sing about.
I don't have a problem with that.
It's the end product where
there seems to be
something not quite right.
The settlement was the right thing to do.
The value of the settlement,
I think, was wrong.
When you think about it now
it's only a drop in the bucket.
There are about 138
government-recognized iwi today.
And they all have their own specific
historical grievances with the Crown.
As of 2022, there have been nearly
80 settlements passed into law.
These claims generally work like this.
Iwi must register a historical claim
with the Waitangi Tribunal to
have their grievances heard
and to proceed in the settlement process.
If their claims are deemed well-founded
they can begin the process of
direct negotiation with the Crown.
After what can be years of back and forth
eventually, they write the final
deed of settlement
that both parties sign.
To receive the settlement assets
iwi must set up a governance entity
that administers the wins
on behalf of the community
often putting the money towards
business development
health and education for the entire group...
not checks to individuals.
The list of what Māori are seeking is long.
It includes millions of dollars,
apologies, the return of land
waters, fisheries, minerals and the
restoration of te reo Māori
the Māori language.
And no two settlements
or the experience of negotiating them
are the same.
But many people live here,
Waikato-Tainui
the first iwi to settle in 1995
as a model for what settlements could be.
As the first iwi to settle
they laid the groundwork
for all the settlements that followed in 1995.
In 1995, the Crown recognized
the unlawful theft
of more than a million acres of
Waikato lands in the 1860s
and settled with the iwi for $170 million.
This was a time in this country
where settlements were new.
It was against public opinion.
It certainly was a courageous move
on the part of the government at that time.
Queen Elizabeth signed
this treaty settlement
which to this day is one of the
largest sums of money
given to an Iwi.
"This is the first time the Queen
has ever signed any law in public."
That was the pinnacle of all apologies.
Most apologies are given by the Crown,
by the government.
In this instance, it was the only apology
made by Queen Elizabeth II.
That we were the only tribe
to get that formal apology
in a signed letter from her is huge.
Because it was an admission
of their guilt
of their wrongdoing and their injustice.
The settlement was successful
but also controversial.
For one, the iwi was criticized
for signing with the Crown
just months after dozens of iwi nationwide
rejected the government's $1 billion
fiscal cap on the settlements.
And the settlement only provided
the return of around 30,000 acres.
It's an insignificant amount of land.
When you compare with that which we lost.
One big win was the Te Rapa base
which they developed into a shopping district
a move to bring them economic independence.
The settlement also included the $15 million
Waikato-Tainui College
which has helped them invest in education.
Anyone who wants to do business
in our tribal area
and they'll come talk to us.
We're undeniable now.
Things have changed.
In 2010, Waikato Tainui
finalized another settlement.
This time it was for the longest river
in New Zealand
from which the iwi takes its name,
the Waikato River.
We got an agreement that gave us equal say.
And anything that happened on the river,
in the river, around the river.
So for me, as a negotiator,
for my iwi people, my tribe...
was the greatest honor of all.
The job that we did
was was minor
compared to the hundreds of our ancestors
who died in the battles.
For our land, for who we are.
For our way of life.
They paid a huge sacrifice
for us to sit in those offices
and try to get a deal with the government
in order to resolve
our outstanding claims against the Crown.
For other iwi the settlements
haven't been as large
and they've taken decades to negotiate.
I'm here at Ngati Maru's
official settlement ceremony.
Where a representative from the Crown
is going to deliver an official apology.
The Crown makes the following apology
to Ngati Maru.
The Crown's many breaches of
Te Tiriti o Waitangi...
left Ngati Maru...
feeling like refugees in their own homeland.
Its confiscation of half of the Ngati Maru...
was indiscriminate
and unwarranted.
The Crown acknowledges that.
Its imprisoned members of Ngati Maru...
assaulted the human rights of the people
residing there and forcibly removed
many inhabitants, destroyed,
and desecrated their homes
and sacred buildings
stolen heirlooms.
The Crown expresses profound remorse
and apologizes.
Ngati Maru's settlement included
$30 million in cash
the return of 17 land titles
and the right to purchase 36 Crown properties
including the Te Wera Forest.
I am humbled to have delivered
these words to you today.
I know how many of you will be
thinking of those loved ones
who were lost before they had a chance
to hear the Crown apologize for its wrongdoing.
I pay tribute to you.
We all know once you lose your land,
you lose your culture, you lose your reo
or you lose your identity,
you lose everything.
So we have been in a process of reclamation...
and rejuvenation and revitalization.
Ultimately, many Māori see the settlements
as an avenue for empowerment and restitution
but they ignore know the issues.
Some iwi have expressed that they don't necessarily
believe the Crown apology to be genuine
and it's something that the Crown does
for their own benefit to release themselves of...
I don't know, perhaps burden
or guilt over those historical breaches.
Ultimately, the ministers of the Crown
get final decisions
on the level of quantum,
the level of financial redress...
you know what land parcels
might be available to come back.
What what we're giving away
in the likes of land, water,
the air we breathe...
is billions.
All stolen property should be returned.
It's like a car. It's a stolen car.
Your car was taken with everything in the car.
Everything taken.
Then they give you your car back with no motor in it.
Just the wheel.
You can't move it.
You can't drive it.
Yeah.
We want the whole car.
Today, Aotearoa is 27 years into
their settlement process.
For some, these settlements have meant
life changing differences
in business opportunities and education.
In many categories, like median household income
Māori outcomes have improved
but they still fall behind Pākehā.
I see settlements as a...
reparation.
I think reparations are
far too nice a word.
You can't embrace the cruelty...
the injustice...
the loss of life.
This is about righting a wrong.
We're talking about blood here.
These kinds of complications are echoed
in the reparations debate in the United States.
Some people say that there's
no amount of money
that could ever compensate
for slavery or for land loss.
And people say that reparations
would further divide
the United States.
But what the Māori process shows us
is that you have to start
with acknowledging the past.
"An apology for slavery and
the Jim Crowe laws...
which for a century after emancipation..."
The Senate apologized for slavery
and Jim Crow in 2009.
"Today, the Senate will unanimously
makes that apology."
But made no mention of reparations.
And while the US apologized
to Native Americans
for acts of violence and neglect...
the statement was largely buried
in the back of a 2010 defense bill.
Even though Aotearoa can't be an
exact model for the United States...
Māori have a direct message
for people in the US.
The fight for reparations is worth it.
I know it sounds like
it's never going to happen.
But truly, there comes a point
where they have to start to listen.
The struggle might be long
and full of uncertainty.
But if the US continues to push
the reparations debate forward
people here could gain
land, money...
better policies and new pathways to healing.
Just like the Māori.